[Musik]
die schweizweite die re sanktionen gegen
russland aus damit schließt sie sich den
maßnahmen der eu an
wohnsitz eines russischen oligarchen in
den bündner bergen guten tag ich stehe
jetzt hier vor der haustüre von herrn
schenk sind sie sitzt us-regierung nahm
ist gaben die aber viel zu wenig genau
eine unruhe auf den rohstoff
handelsplatz zug und dadurch ein tier
besonders
habe sich doch nichts
oder regierung polizei oder spiele und
jetzt die firma abklappern und morgen
ist alles in ordnung also ihk schlüsse
die party mit den russen war gestern
jetzt geht's ans aufräumen der bundesrat
übernimmt sämtliche vorgaben der eu und
setzt sie ins nationale richtung es gibt
also keine einzige ausnahme
wir wollen wissen wie die schweiz das
macht mit diesen russland sanktionen und
begeben uns auf spurensuche in bern zug
und st moritz
[Musik]
explosionen sind in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew zu hören der russische
präsident wladimir putin hat eine
militäraktion in der ukraine angeordnet
24 februar
2022 am tag an dem der russische
präsident wladimir putin den blick
beginnt bestellte ausgewählte
oligarchien in den kreml
alles was jetzt passiert war eine
notwendige maßnahme
sie ließen uns keine andere wahl
unter den 36 oligarchen ist auch andrej
melnitschenko
manager wohnt in der schweiz und er hat
einen firmenhauptsitz in der schweiz
putin hat nach dem mageren fünf die
ukraine natürlich die öffentlichkeit der
russische öffentlichkeit gegenüber
müssen zeigen dass das eine gute aktion
ist der mätresse wo russland und der
raum user
grund die oligarchen debatte und die
haben denn jeder müsse für kamera und
sagen das ist gut und die sanktion
machen und
ich bin bei thomas borer ehemalige
schweizer botschafter heute lobbyist uns
berater brücken sich aus mit russischen
oligarchen bis 2010 hatte viktor
wechselberg beraten dann habe er einen
schlussstrich gezogen sagt er
oligarchen abhängig vor ihm da so machen
und denen sind wir weg sind die zwei
wochen überrascht wenn sie jemand immer
aber sei will den landes in sibirien
aber unter uns gesagt jetzt beschämend
dass bis heute sehr viel oligarchen sich
nicht vom pult in hand rauer
distanzieren das zeigt wie sie
eigentlich bis zum innersten abhängig
sind vor ihm
andrej melnitschenko kohle unternehmer
und einer der größten
düngemittelproduzenten weltweit
das ist ein sehr großes industrieprojekt
viele milliarden dollar werden
investiert und viele arbeitsplätze
geschaffen
der multi milliardär ist seit dem 19
märz auf der eu sanktionsliste
eine woche später kommt er auf die
sanktionsliste der schweiz
für die eu ist klar weil manager bei
kriegsausbruch an putins oligarchischen
treffen teilgenommen hat gehört er zum
engsten wirtschaftskreis des russischen
präsidenten die sanktions behörde
schreibt zitat
ferner wird daran deutlich dass er zu
den führenden geschäftsleuten gehört die
in bereichen der wirtschaft tätig sind
die der regierung der russischen
föderation die für die annexion der krim
und die destabilisierung der ukraine
verantwortlich ist aus wichtige
einnahmequelle dienen
wir sind in den bündner bergen im
nobelkurort st moritz hier hat andere
manager offiziell seinen hauptwohnsitz
am 14 august 2009 hatte das haus gekauft
einer villa am suvretta house am tag als
in die schweiz auf die sanktionsliste
setzt gehe ich zu seinem wohnsitz
hallo
guten tag hallo mein name ist kathrin
winzenried von schweizer fernsehen sind
sie sind sie da also diese nummer ist
hier angegeben
also sind sie sind in deutschland und
sie sind der hausrat oder
er arbeitet seit jahren für die familie
managen co und er habe für diesen job
eine schweige klausel unterschrieben
ok und sie dürfen wahrscheinlich auch
keine auskunft erteilen über den lohn
diesen monats noch erhalten wird weiß er
nichts von angestellten andere
sanktionierte oligarchen habe gehört sie
hätten den job bereits verloren ich
danke ihnen herzlich und wünsche ihnen
alles gute
auf wiederhören
andrej melnitschenko gehört zu den
wenigen russischen oligarchen die auf
der sanktionsliste stehen uns in der
schweiz wohnsitz haben eine handvoll ist
bis jetzt öffentlich bekannt in st
polizist managern co einer von rund 100
pauschalbesteuerten wie häufiger hier
oben war bleibt unklar hier eines der
wenigen fotos von ihm in sankt moritz
private cocktail party in der galerie
gmurzynska
zufällig treffen wir vor ort eine frau
die manager kennt eine hausangestellte
sie bei einer anderen familie arbeitet
manchmal sehe ich sie auf der straße
[Musik]
sie veranstalten auf partys und dinis
was man von außen sieht es nicht das was
es wirklich ist viel versteckt sich im
berg viele räume spaß solche dinge
warum wissen sie das
weil ich die angestellten kennen
es gibt leute die das ganze jahr hier
sind und den unterhalt machen so wie ich
wenn die besitzer kommen und bringen sie
das personal mit
ja das ganze team
küchenpersonal babysitter putzequipe
skilehrer taxi butler
[Musik]
ungefähr zum zeitpunkt der filmaufnahmen
meldet das bündner grundbuchamt die
liegenschaft in bern
vermögenswert eines sanktionierten
oligarchien der von amtes wegen
eingefroren werden muss
doch was heißt eingefroren thomas borer
erklärt
in aller regel ist es so dass
user wohnhaus und familie diene hätte
wieder benutzen und dass man die ausgabe
womit ein normaler unterhalb von deinbus
verbunden sind abartig aber da muss man
eben eine bewilligung bitter sanktions
behörde holte mit bank die zahlung mache
jetzt erwähnen sie flugzeuge ist oder
der chef das könnt ihr jetzt nicht um
normale ladens unterhalt kann ich der
fuß dass das im ausland nun bewilligt
wird und ich glaube dass schweizer die
benutzung von derartigen bewillige
die guardia di finanza die italienische
finanzpolizei demonstriert medienwirksam
wie man es macht die teuerste segel
yacht der welt wird am freitag 11 märz
im hafen von triest dicht gemacht ihr
besitzer der oligarch aus sankt moritz
andrej melnitschenko
managers luxusschiff mit seiner länge
von 143 metern und einem wert von rund
500 millionen dollar wird wohl für lange
zeit sie untauglich bleiben in der
schweiz hat der russische oligarch er zu
diesem zeitpunkt noch freie hand die
eidgenossen hinkenden eu-sanktionen
massiv hinterher
putin hält das kwf der individuelle gar
nicht das erklären die welt senior liegt
was gewohnt sie macht das tierbaby
milliarden verfüge große geschäft machen
unschöne yacht club und das kann ich sie
alles nehmen
[Musik]
das waren noch zeiten russische
silvester an der zürcher bahnhofstrasse
gastgeberin die hoteldirektorin
liebermanns
[Musik]
muss das glas einschenken bis voll an
den rand und essex austrinken und das
wegwerfen und das heißt dass das leben
soll voll zahlen bis zum letzten tropfen
soll man es genießen und dann die höhle
ganz einfach abstreifen
manz ist gebürtige ukrainerin gefeiert
wurde an ihren anlässen aber stets
russland
und die schweizer high society feierte
gerne mit
im moment ist der haupt besuchte das
virus sibirische kälte hoffe dass das am
rietzer see zurück früher das neue das
poloturnier vor konturen höre
jetzt wo die party vorbei ist hätten wir
gerne mit liebermanns über die
sanktionen gegen russland gesprochen um
zu erfahren was sie davon hält
sie habe kein interesse an einem
interview ließ sie ausrichten
[Musik]
auch am zürcher paradeplatz ist russland
derzeit ein heikles thema namentlich bei
der credit suisse die hat russischen
oligarchen in der vergangenheit geholfen
ihre privatflugzeuge und yachten zu
finanzieren
das hat die britische financial times
kürzlich aufgedeckt
der journalist robert smith staunte
nicht schlecht als ihm
hedgefonds-manager berichteten die
credit suisse habe versucht ihnen ein
finanzprodukt anzudrehen in dem die cs
kredite für yachten und privatflugzeuge
zusammengefasst hatte amina spot
präsentation für die investoren zeigt
schwarz auf weiß dass die credit suisse
russischen oligarchen geholfen hat ihre
jets und die akten zu finanzieren
bei der credit suisse ist die enthüllung
der financial times offenbar schlecht
angekommen kurz darauf passierte
folgendes
russland hat mit der invasion der
ukraine begonnen was uns alle schockiert
in der woche darauf hörte ich sehr
seltsame dinge einige der investoren auf
die swiss im zusammenhang mit diesen
fiel zugegangen ist wie kamen plötzlich
briefe von der credit suisse
da stand drin wir fordern sie auf alle
dokumente die wir ihnen gegeben haben
dauerhaft zu löschen the documents
verletzung ist er um die credit suisse
sagt die aufforderung zur
aktenvernichtung sei ein ganz normaler
vorgang
intern seien die daten noch vorhanden
keine mit dem ich gesprochen habe konnte
sich erinnern dass eine bank je solche
briefe verschickt hat dass dokumente
dauerhaft vernichtet werden sollten für
die bank ist es eine sehr sensible zeit
darum will sie das über ihre geschäfte
mit oligarchen so wenig wie möglich
bekannt
mit den sanktionen setzt die usa den
schweizer finanzplatz im nacken da gibt
es noch andere dinge die zwar legal sind
und trotzdem in der kritik stehen als
problem vom finanzplatz schweiz ist das
illegal sondern auch andere vermögen der
lügt hilft doch schachtel struktur mit
vielen
firmengründungen in
andere stadt panama peru das etc
der eigentliche eigentümer die
wirtschaftlich berechtigt die
verstecke
insbesondere interessieren ja die
sanktionen im finanzbereich und ich
etwas näher darauf ein im finanzbereich
ist es einmal für die schweiz von
absolut zentralem interesse dass die
integrität des finanzplatzes schweiz
gewährleistet ist bundesrat ueli maurer
sagte da auch russische kundengelder
figurierten in der schweizer vermögens
branche unter ferner liefen
später wurde die zahl konkret immerhin
rund 200 milliarden dollar aus russland
liegen bei schweizer banken ein großer
teil davon oligarchen geld doch wie gut
sind die schweizer wenn es jetzt ums
jagen von solchen vermögenswerten geht
kollege simon christen ist unterwegs an
der badestraße in zug eine drehscheibe
physische rohstoffe
430 briefkasten am briefkasten nicht
wenige davon von rohstofffirmen wie zb
bereits ein stahl und bergbaukonzern und
dem roman abramowitsch beteiligt ist
oder
die inzwischen zahlungsunfähigen nord
stream zwei ag
die finanzdirektion des kantons zug ist
ebenfalls angesagt der baarerstrasse zu
hause wir haben einen termin beim
verantwortlichen regierungsrat
wird sich richter vom schweizer
fernsehen
ich will vom finanzdirektor wissen was
er bisher unternommen hat in bezug auf
sanktionierten firmen und personen
aber das ist ja nicht doof gab pfizer
der familie mit den ängsten
auseinandersetzen und dehnen und
ausgeliefert die sanktion des initiator
und es ist ihm mit ruhiger wenn wir
aktion machte trifft wieder und ja also
kommen sie vermögenswerte haben normale
musik
kommt der meister das jetzt machen
euro cabrio vom tischler jan überhaupt
nötig probst in ton mit dem viele immer
ähnlich volt für uns intern den letzten
stand up
frage die
sanktion wolfsburger klug rätselt der
chemie hat er sich vom sofort wieder
groß mehr vermögenswerte haben wir seit
der erhebung von firmen womöglich wie es
weitergeht dann wie jetzt euro kein
geschenk und sowie drei stück ist
übermütig bis über den
erfolg der aktion von mir nie als wir an
ihr bis überhaupt
danke
wir tragen bei der sanktions berührte
sektor nach das seco schreibt uns die
meldepflicht gelte auch ohne vorgängige
information durch die schweizer behörde
einfacher gesagt als getan
bei der steuerverwaltung im kanton
graubünden gibt es unklarheiten müssen
nun vermögenswerte des oligarchischen
manager die nur in den steuerunterlagen
ersichtlich sind gemeldet werden und
selbstverständlich halte - als kantonale
steuerverwaltung an dir vor ort nicht
aber das problem ist es ist nicht klar
stand wir die
afrikanisch oder anders zeit steht
überhaupt nicht fest ob stuhl verwaltung
von der meldepflicht bezirks der
verordnung vom bund betroffen sind mehr
hin schließlich storck eines im kanton
graubünden ist das sehr strikte und
jetzt gilt's zum prüfer das
spannungsverhältnis zwischen
einstieg eines einerseits und ein
allfälliger meldepflicht stützt die
bundesverordnung anders siehts treffer
und den entscheider bei der sanktions
behörde säcke gibt es zu dieser frage
keine klare ansage ich frage mich was
nach unterhalte schließlich die antwort
die steuerbehörden seien je nach fall
meldepflichtig mit anderen worten das
seco lässt die kantone hängen
an der bahnstraße in zug treffen
schweizer behörden und firmen mit
russland bezug und deren hoch
spezialisierte anwälte aufeinander zb
euro m und zweck weiter bis vor kurzem
kontrolliert von andrej melnitschenko
dem oligarchen aus dem bündnerland
sanktionen gegen solche firmen werden
jetzt gefordert jetzt ist es aber so
dass nicht nur kritiklosen kantons hund
oder aus der schweizer internationale
kritik am konto zug heißt zum beispiel
besser ist als juso für russische firmen
im kanton zug das bloomberg oder
schrieben haben ja stimmt sich business
as usual
nein nicht einfach besser sein und
einfach die augen verschließen mit denen
diese aufgabe korrekte findet wo mir
zustand um ihren einflussbereich und
außenpolitik machte bund muss politik
machen nicht erkannt und zu was ist ein
grad verstand die kraft ihrer direktion
in der frage
welcher frage jetzt in zwei mal an mit
denen sanktionen und wie die umgesetzt
wird ich hatte mir daheim ihr daheim im
aufgabenkatalog detonieren fülle und
wenn wir vom bund musste wie er sie
können sich einfach überhand nehmen mit
dem mixed duo sie mir ist
erfreulicherweise der finanzdirektion
jetzt auf liegenden aufgabe
kartenprogramm ich halte mich haben die
gesetze dass er war die kabine mit
arbeiten von ihnen an der ich halte mir
konstantes und so weiter und so fort und
wenn sanktionen
ergriffen werden oder vom bund verfügt
ein medium setzen punkt
am 9 märz kommt andrej melnitschenko auf
die sanktionsliste der eu am gleichen
tag zieht er sich auch seinen beiden
firmen euro m und zweck zurück und
verkauft aktienanteile nur mit seinem
rückzug kann der betrieb
aufrechterhalten werden doch wo ist das
geld das der oligarch aus dem
aktienverkauf löste die schweizer
behörden kümmert das nicht beim bund
kommt er erst eine woche später auf die
sanktionsliste darum sei man nicht
zuständig sagt das seco und auch der
kanton zug weiß von nichts
mitbekommt dass ich mehr mitbekommt
möglicher wie sich das stück verwaltung
zuständige person bisher bekannt aber
dann muss ich auch sagen ich muss nicht
die schiere und einen detektiv den naga
das ergibt sich automatisch was dort
passiert also die informationen die
musik die muss ich nicht im detail ich
sehe im moment keine konkreten
bedarf und die frühere zumal auch zur
war damit attackiert und meine
überschüsse und männer über aktionismus
sondern jetzt wo die krise noch mal eine
krise weil sie muslime wie sich das
international entwickelt und wenn wir
irgendwo anbieter
am horizont licht gerät dann muss man
nicht einmal mehr das spätere krise
haben sich unsere krise macht fliegt
dann überlegte analysieren und wirken ob
es allenfalls irgendwelche
assistieren gebucht
[Musik]
gerne hätten die vor der kamera mit der
sanktions behörde seko über diese suche
nach geld und vermögenswerten gesprochen
doch das amt winkt ab die belastung fürs
personal sei derzeit zu groß die behörde
schreibt uns allgemein das seco habe
sich für eine meldepflicht uns gegen
eine jagd auf vermögenswerte entschieden
das seco sei keine finanzpolizei um die
sanktionen umzusetzen habe man eine
kleine task force eingerichtet
ich treffe markiert er meditierte
strafrechtsprofessor und geldwäscherei
experte er kann die zögerliche art
dersekow nicht nachvollziehen ich bete
meine das saarland wo eine derartige
exposition hat mit russland in der lage
sie muss
reagieren
sanktionen dass sie schon mit norris hat
mich in zither cream annexion himmel
sanktionen gegen russ also
wahrscheinlich nie gespielt die sagt man
muss wissen wie es läuft und wenn sie
ein oder zwei personen hin wo zuständig
sind denn ich das mindestens so viel
inkompetenz
deco 67 tag braucht für die
redaktionsarbeit leichter von der
ehefrau nicht
fertig was sagt dazu dann ja das ist
enorm schädlich für den ruf für der
schweiz und sich vielleicht schlimmer
oder sich vielleicht
taktik wo
silvester möglicher neues geld ins
trockene bringen das rätsel ums geld von
andrej melnichenko seinen
aktienverkäufen bleibt ungelöst die
offizielle schweiz interessiert sich
nichts dafür
der betroffene manager sagt nichts dazu
in sankt moritz sind die sanktionen ein
thema doch lieber nicht öffentlich
erstaunlich denn in der vergangenheit
war die verbindung zu russland nie ein
problem
[Musik]
ja
nun laufen die fäden die sich gutes tun
über geld ausgeben wollen das lustig
haben entsprechend sind sagt raith aus
der fusion zahlen die hardware ist die
betriebe die lokale die mit dem bus
fahren die profitieren die russen sind
für uns natürlich sehr wichtig wie
decken etwa 150 skilehrer die in dieser
zeit unterwegs sind mit russischen
gästen wussten die hier in sand gebiet
sind die sind sehr
wertschöpfungsintensive
[Musik]
russen pflaster nennt man sankt moritz
auch darum möchte ich vom
gemeindepräsidenten wissen welche
auswirkungen die sanktionen auf den
kurort haben doch dieser winkt ab er der
nie um einen spruch verlegen ist und
sich auf der internetseite der gemeinde
so präsentiert
die gemeinde sankt moritz dass ich
großes oval office dauerte stube der
gemeindeverwaltung wird alles
kommandiert kontrolliert und regiert und
das macht sogar nur spaß der sonst so
kommunikative gemeindepräsident reagiert
auf unsere anfrage mit einer dürren e
mail
das verhältnis russische gäste ist in
unserer gemeinde vernichtend klein rund
2,3 prozent es ist für uns deshalb kein
grund der sorge respektive der
kommunikation ich bitte sie um
verständnis
ich rufe ihn an
also der name gestellt ob die das
politische richtig findet
sämtliche gemeinden der sänger dienst
hätten entschieden die sanktionen und
deren auswirkungen nicht öffentlich zu
kommentieren sagt mit christian jott
jenny
tatsächlich sind die logiernächte
russische gäste in sankt moritz
zurückgegangen in den letzten jahren
gemäss statistik des kantons graubünden
konsumieren sie allerdings nach wie vor
weit mehr als der schweizer
durchschnitts gast
ich treffe silvia affolter ehemalige
miss schweiz und heute unternehmerin
silvia affolter ist bestens vernetzt in
sankt moritz seit zwei jahren wohnt sie
auch im oberen gardinen
doch natürlich
von ihr will ich wissen warum das mit
den sanktionen hier oben so ein heikles
thema ist
mir natürlich so die berichte zur ihre
berichte als ich nicht irgendwer
billiges pflaster das ist doch nie was
ich spüre es ist irgendwie das
schließlich erlaubt sanktionen wird für
das schließlich erlaubt kreditkarte
einfach irgendwie zu früheren dass die
lücken zu nichts fähig sind das verstört
und sie fragen sich wer ist dann als
nächste dran sind völlig saudis oder
weil ist die italienische mafia wer
bestimmten überhaupt was das rätseln wer
hat bloß geld oder hat sie befürwortet
die sanktionen gegen russland man müsse
alles menschenmögliche unternehmen um
leid und elend in der ukraine möglichst
schnell zu stoppen und dann erzählt sie
mir noch eine geschichte die da oben
derzeit die runde macht den ruß offenbar
hat wenig mit liedern wie armani über
220 die musik frank raether sicher auch
nicht wenig und dann nicht kreditkarte
gesperrt sie und der hubschrauber der
ober in sankt moritz kranich hatten
geschäftsführer im armani und armani
persönlich ab und fragten was ich und
dann hat der kunde ja nein das ist eine
langjährige und der firma nicht einfach
so stark an dem sich
zellen mit magath dann später
gekappte zahlungsverkehr in sankt moritz
bis dato ein unbekanntes und
unvorstellbares problem
russen geld ist derzeit auch in zug das
thema nummer eins zb bei anastasia kelly
die an der baarerstrasse im büro hat die
gebürtige russin bietet seit zwölf
jahren einen exklusiven service für
reiche russen sie organisiert den umzug
in die schweiz vom aushandeln einer
pauschalbesteuerung über die suche nach
einer immobilie bis zur privatschule für
die kinder sei der krieg in der ukraine
begonnen habe sei ihm zu groß anders
sagt sie ihr geschäft stehe still und
ausfluss ihn hatte sie sich zurück bei
diskussionen
nicht thema politik lieber nicht
ja weil das ist sehr schmerzhaft für die
und auch für mich weil es ist sehr sehr
heikle thema
wer sich aus russin zu erkennen gebe sei
derzeit anfeindungen ausgesetzt
das höre sie immer wieder von ihren
kunden sogar die kinder würden
angegangen kann
man gehöre dass sich einige tage nach
dem nach dem krieg ausbruch
in die schule vor allem also die von
meine kunden sind
die anderen kind beschimpft quasi dass
die russen sind dass sie
aber das
krieg gefallen könnte als die politik
gegangen und wollte die kinder
gar nicht damit zu tun aber die kinder
sie sie wissen dass er auch nicht die
kleine kinder können nicht sich hören
nur an die erwachsenen sagen
anastasia kelly hat von den eltern
dieser kinder in den letzten jahren sehr
gut gelebt von russen die weg wollten
aus russland mit dem problem von shine
wohnsitzen sie kam nie konfrontiert
worden sagt sie ich kann nicht sagen
dass auch alle 100 prozent
wirklich in die schweiz wohnen weil
es gibt teilweise noch familie die man
sie auch besucher es gibt business
weltweit muss dass er auch also man muss
sich liberal reise und aber dass man
wirklich nur die adresse da in die
schweiz hat und wie gewohnt grad das
sind ich
meine kunden hätten das mega weil die
schätzen auch die schwebt die schätzen
auch die diese natur diese
wunderschöne so das was alles eigentlich
schwach weil was dies alles bietet sie
schätzen das sehr und ich würde nicht
sagen dass mini kulisse glücklich hier
nur für für die grenze aber
gut da so sind sie sicher
ob zug seine anziehungskraft für reiche
russen bewahren kann ist laut gygi offen
dass die schweiz inzwischen firmen und
personen sanktioniere sei bei ihr sehr
schlecht angekommen
die schweiz ist nicht mehr neutral
das heißt das was vorher eine oase von
sicherheit sie von neutralität die
lücken immer gewusst dass man könnte
vertrauen man könnte ich hier leben dass
es jetzt nicht mehr so das heißt auch
dirigieren könnte von torfmooren
konto informieren und durchaus nicht
weil zugang zu hinten irgendwo klar dass
das das verhindert dass das bleibt im
kopf
wieder in sankt moritz fotopapier
charity dinner für die ukraine
eine auktion steht auf dem programm
kunstwerke einen aus der ukraine
geflüchteten künstlerin werden
versteigert der erlös des abends geht an
hilfswerke
für anlass steht unter dem motto sankt
moritz kann auch anders sein
will jetzt hier
[Gelächter]
wäre aus und bediente toni kross könnt
ihr noch ein monster du verloren keine
wirklich sinnlos da passiert jedoch dass
ich meine sache
also
jetzt hat denn
andere deshalb mit orden drei
andere kriminelle
[Gelächter]
ein bunte gäste mix aus alteingesessenen
und zugezogenen kommt an diesem abend
zusammen
[Musik]
40000 franken werden an diesem abend
gesammelt und gehen in die ukraine
[Musik]
andrej melnitschenko der besitzer dieses
hauses ist weit weg außerhalb des
sanktions gebietes in die schweiz
einreisen könne nicht mehr er werde den
sanktions entscheid anfechten schreibt
einer seiner sprecher melnitschenko habe
keinen bezug zu den tragischen
ereignissen in der ukraine
er sei für den frieden
[Musik]